video has gone viral over another TSA
pat down this one is of a kid that looks
to be based on my analysis somewhere
between 3 and 18 years old I'm just
really bad at figuring out how old kids
are as many of you know I always opted
out of the porno scanner at airports and
opted for a pat-down lately I haven't
had to because I have TSA PreCheck now
where you go through a regular metal
detector instead of the porno scanner
but I've had my fair share of TSA
pat-downs and for whatever reason this
particular pat-down that we're going to
show our video audience has gone viral
even though it's not super clear that
anything wrong is going on beyond the
general ineffective nature of how the
TSA operates and what's at issue here is
not so much the content of the video but
also how its spread the pat-down took
place in 2017 a woman named Jennifer
Williamson filmed her son getting this
pat-down she says her son as a sensory
processing disorder took place at
dallas-fort Worth Airport almost a
two-year old video and the reason that
it has gone viral now is that it was
shared Monday by a Twitter account
called deep State exposed which is a key
one on conspiracy Twitter account
conservative actor James Woods retweeted
it then comedian Larry the Cable Guy
retweeted it and ultimately this chain
of insanity got to Donald Trump
retweeting this video saying not a good
situation about the now nearly two-year
old pat-down and all of a sudden people
are up in arms about this so I want to
kind of break it down in pieces in
general are these TSA pat-downs
ridiculous in a sense they are it's
unclear how safe the TSA is keeping us
in these self-tests that the TSA has
done a 19 out of 20 as many as 95% of
banned items that they try to send
through as a self test get through
there's a lot of security theater and
then we get to the question of is there
sometimes inappropriate behavior by TSA
agents the answer is of course there's a
story from years ago about
TSA touching a woman's vagina that we
covered the TSA officers who were fired
gropings scheme there are many
individual stories but this particular
pat-down that is now gone viral thanks
to Donald Trump took two minutes that's
typical they take 90 to 120 seconds in
my very extensive experience with these
pat-downs they did all the same things
to the kid as they've done to me every
time following the exact order that they
always do checking the waistband in a
particular way wearing the rubber gloves
all of the different stuff um and if
they should have done it differently
because the kid has a sensory disorder
okay well we can talk about that but to
call the pat-down particularly
outrageous is silly and people like
Trump are fueling the conspiratorial
fire which is being spread by this deep
state exposed twitter account that this
is part of some kind of TSA groping
scheme and of course there's no evidence
of that whatsoever so when I would look
at this video Pat and I don't know if
you opted for pat downs or if you go
through the porno scanner or what
it doesn't seem any more outrageous than
the average TSA pat down that I've had
her seen no I think we're just more
sensitive to it because you're dealing
with someone who's underage here and it
just seems inappropriate it seems like
it's going on for way too long I just go
through the porno scanner I guess I'm
just not so hypersensitive to these
things but I can certainly see how it
can bother some people by the way let's
pull out the video of my pat-down years
and years ago at Hartford Airport when I
lived in western Massachusetts you'll
see me in this video smiling ear-to-ear
you'll you'll hear my girlfriend say
that it's for a show when they tell her
to stop recording which I don't think
was the best idea to say but it still
ended up with some funny video and I
apologize it's just 55 seconds I know
it's very visual if you're just
listening today a lot of this won't make
sense but you'll hear very quickly TSA
does not want my pat-down recorded
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
then when was the further video taken
[Music]
I'm like here we go I'm legally on the
last word
[Music]
legally I'm allowed to and he offers
here four he asked me to for a show I
instructed her do not stop recording no
matter what that's the key thing if they
tell you not to record just keep
recording and she did and we got some
funny video from it so anyway the real
story here is that Trump is retweeting
Larry the Cable guy's Q and on
conspiracy theory how does the guy have
time for this stuff really really
bizarre one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is simple habit an app that
provides a massive library of really
excellent five minute guided meditations
they're letting everybody in our
audience use it completely free for one
week when you go to simple habit comm
slash Pakman we've talked a lot on the
program about the growing scientific
evidence pointing to the benefits of
meditation and what really sets simple
habit apart is the variety of guided
meditations that they offer more than
2,000 made for many different issues
that you may be dealing with if you need
help
falling asleep if you have anxiety that
you're dealing with if you want to be
more productive during the day they have
meditations specifically tailored for
certain times of day like when you're
waking up or your commute to work or
when you've just gotten home from work
I'm a huge advocate of meditation myself
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day and each meditation
takes just five minutes and they're very
easy to follow maybe you want to feel
more grounded before you start your day
at work or at school maybe you want to
keep your mind a little more clear so
that it's easier to accomplish your
goals or you just want a calmer more
peaceful experience throughout your day
simple habit can help you get there it
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app it's available on
Android iOS and web browser and you can
try it completely free for a week check
it out go to simple habit calm slash
Pakman I've put a
link down below underneath the video